this is the new front line in the
nation's fight against kovid
fears over the outbreak of the indian
variant in bolton have
fueled a surge in vaccine uptake the
prime minister hopes it's enough to keep
his roadmap
on track but people here worried about
what happens if he's wrong
if people carry on ignoring these
vaccines then
yeah i think we possibly might go back
into a local lockdown which
will just take us back to stage one
again it won't happen he can't do it
we've been in lockdown for
far too long we do hope that this will
end quicker and the fact that we can get
our vaccinations done at a walking
centre like this
uh it does give us a bit of hope are you
losing the fight against the varian
prime minister
after days on the back foot the pm with
some good news
we have increasing confidence that
vaccines are effective
against all variants including
the indian variant but vaccine's not the
only tool in the arsenal
long queues for surge testing too today
expanded to eight new areas across the
country
an urgent hunt for the variant as cases
rise by over a quarter in two days
the health secretary playing for time
we'll look every day at the data
and we'll make a final decision on the
on on
whether we can go ahead with step four
um and we'll make
and publish that decision on the on the
14th of june
until then it is just too early to say
but hope too that the worst case
scenario may be avoided
we have a credible range that goes from
a few percent
more transmissible through to
50 percent more transmissible i think
most people feel it is going to be
somewhere in the middle
the prime minister always knew that
there would be bumps along the road to
freedom indeed one cabinet minister said
to me this was never going to be
a linear path but the question now is
whether the indian variant might throw
the government completely
off course senior government figures
tell me the early data's encouraging
both in terms of transmissibility
and vaccine effectiveness but this is
a waiting game and a tense one at that
with
allies of the prime minister admitting
that any delay to june the 21st
will be politically very damaging
freedom has been a long time coming and
as we get to the home straight the race
between the vaccine and the virus
tightening
government figures now more confident
they'll win out the next few days of
data will be key
beth rigby sky news westminster